[Musique]
ah ouais c'est mon vrai nom je crois
godrèche époux j'aurais été trouvé ça
depuis que je suis né j'ai toujours
voulu faire du cinéma et j'ai vu un jour
une petite annonce quoi comme pas mal de
jury qui font du cinéma je crois c'est
ça en fait c'est ça qui a été ma chance
ce départ
moi j'ai eu un agent par les mendiants
jeanrichard médias où était aussi doyon
et il m'a envoyée rencontrer doyon juste
comme ça pour rien de spécial et je suis
allé leur ventre et on a discuté pendant
une demi heure est au bout d'une demi
heure il m'a dit je veux faire un film
sur toi il y avait un mais et le mais
c'était comme j'avais raconté j'écrivais
des trucs et tous tes poèmes les machins
il m'a dit mais je voudrais que tu écrit
le scénario
non
[Musique]
en
j'ai vraiment envie de faire il ya
vraiment moi quand j'ai lu le scénario
j'étais ravie parce que j'ai vu qu'il
fallait courir qu'il fallait se faire
poursuivre qui avaient des couteaux qui
ça bouge tout le temps quoi
[Musique]
le résumé c'est un
jeune fille de 17 ans rend compte en
trois jours trois hommes de trois âges
différents
moi je trouve pas que c'est ça trouve
c'est quand même plus
c'est pas un film rohmérien c'est pas
c'est pas un film il ya des rencontres
où les rencontres sont sont le sujet du
film quoi ce comme un film sur le destin
d'une jeune fille d'être un destin qui
se joue en trois jours
si je devais dire quels sont les points
communs entre moi le personnage je
dirais que une paria rimbaud je crois
que si benoît amis rimbaud dans le dans
le film c'est à cause de moi et parce
qu'ils savaient que j'adorais rimbaud et
puis il ya cette façon de dire pour
toujours jamais pour toujours jamais
rien du tout cette façon ne pas être du
tout en demi-mesure
non
[Musique]
en
j'ai toujours détesté les cours les
courges a raté écoles pour la fille de
15 ans parce que je détestais ça et
j'avais pris dans des cours de des cours
de théâtre ça va pas du tout ce pas mon
truc
parce que j'ai fait j'ai rencontré des
gens qui sortaient de cours de théâtre
trouvé ça terrifiant comment il s'était
vraiment il avait une espèce n'a eu la
façon de bouger tout tout était en prin
t'es rien et instinctif chez eux sans
lève tout instinct
et des choses que je ferais pas non je
sais pas ce que je ferais pas ça dépend
du metteur en scène par exemple des
scènes de cul
sarlat j'ai horreur de ça mais avec
godard
avant électriques je voulais trapéziste
ouais
ça a changé quoique en fait que je crois
que ça
il n'y a pas beaucoup de différence
mais sachez puisque je me suis présentée
quand j'ai vu tant l'école du cirque qui
m'ont dit qu'il fallait attendre dix ans
et pendant ces deux ans ça a changé je
sais pas pourquoi mais ça a changé c'est
le fait d'attendre
non
j'ai horreur d'attendre pourquoi vous
aimez ça
[Musique]